hi there steve kaufman here um one
question i get asked all the time
is how do you get to speaking can you
talk about your experience in getting
from the sort of passive knowledge of
the language to where you're speaking uh
those of you who have been following my
channel here at youtube or who have read
my blog the linguist on language
will know that i
am a great believer in the value of
input based learning listening and
reading it's just so powerful so
inexpensive it's a great way to spend
your time in building up your language
competence
and building up your vocabulary building
up your ability to understand the
language
making the brain more familiar with the
language but
still we all want to speak the language
that's why we that's why we learn the
language we want to speak
and a lot of people have trouble
speaking or they think they have trouble
speaking
and so the question is how do you get to
speaking well the simple answer is
to speak well you have to speak a lot
okay and when you start speaking at
whatever level you start speaking you're
going to have difficulty
uh in my view uh if i put my most of my
emphasis on listening and reading and
accumulating vocabulary
that that's gonna move me along in my
speaking
more quickly than just relying on
speaking i need words if i want to speak
to people i want it to be a natural
conversation i want to understand what
they have to say
if i were i've been studying chuck now
for two and a half months i haven't
spoken to anyone in czech i haven't i
don't say anything if i were in the
czech republic i probably would speak to
some people but it would be very
difficult it wouldn't be a very
satisfying
experience because probably most many
people in the czech republic
speak
english better than i speak czech
and those that don't who only speak
czech they would come at me so fast in
check i wouldn't understand what they're
saying
so while i would do it
because i'm there and i'd want to take
advantage of the opportunity and
my victories would be few and far
between most of these
forays into speaking with the locals
would end in defeat i'd still do it
because it's good for you
uh but uh i see no need to do it i'm
here in canada i would rather wait until
i have built up my capability in the
language my comprehension skills
listening comprehension vocabulary and
then go and say six months from now and
then i will have a chance to have
meaningful conversations with people but
it doesn't matter some people don't have
the choice they have to start now
and even if you have spent a year
listening and reading when you first
start to speak it's difficult it's
difficult to summon up all these words
that you've been learning and phrases
and start using them but you at some
point you have to break the ice
and so it's very important when you do
start speaking
that you don't get discouraged uh in
everything we do
uh if we're playing a game of tennis
let's say and we play well or golf or or
anything
and we do well we're encouraged to do it
again if we don't do well
we kind of don't feel
very good about ourselves and we don't
want to go back to that experience
because it was a not so satisfactory
experience
uh but then with that attitude you'll
never improve so if i have a poor game
of tennis i feel a little bit badly but
at some level i've got to say i've got
to go and work harder to get better
the same with languages but what's more
with languages in tennis if you do
poorly your opponent defeated you maybe
whereas in languages you can take the
position that you always win
because every time you're using a
foreign language however in however
limited away
you're actually using a skill that you
have invested in and that you have
developed that you didn't have before
like if i speak in check and i don't
understand what the person is saying and
i can't say what i want to say and and i
know i'll forget the most obvious things
like how to say my name is and how are
you
uh but still the little bit that i did
get across or did understand
it's it's an achievement that's what
i've i've achieved over the last two and
a half months
uh plus i know that i understand a lot
when i'm doing my listening and reading
so i i tend not to feel badly about
myself not to say i'm no good or or
whatever i i just keep going at it
because i know
that if you continue to speak you will
improve part of the reason you continue
you will improve if you continue to
speak is because you are hearing you are
again listening which is so powerful
you're listening to what the native
speaker says
and you are noticing how the native
speaker says things that you were trying
to say and you will also notice your own
mistakes and that will make you more
attentive to those mistakes in your own
listening and reading so actually
speaking is a great way to sort of
leverage up your listening and reading
activities but make no mistake you're
going to go through a painful period
where some people will have no patience
to talk to you uh in the language that
you've been learning some will revert to
english some will get
unpleasant and some will be very nice
and patient and and you humor you for a
while
uh but it's going to be a bit of a tough
road uh the longer you spend listening
and reading and building up your
vocabulary the easier the transition is
going to be
to uh speaking but sometimes you don't
have the choice you've arrived in a
country you've got to start speaking
so uh
all i'm saying is there's no easy path
the way you improve your speaking is to
speak more now there are some other uh
things that can help obviously listening
and reading continued listening and
reading intensive listening and reading
when i lived in japan i started speaking
soon after i arrived there
to the extent that i could but the vast
majority of my learning time was still
spent listening and reading building up
my comprehension
skills in my vocabulary now the other
thing you can do is is
you know the words you're going to use
the active vocabulary is obviously a
limited set of your total passive
vocabulary you don't have to use all
your words you don't have to use all
your phrases find some handy words and
phrases that you like to build your
thoughts around you don't have to know
all the ways of saying evidently
obviously clearly
you know these these synonyms uh
which we tend to use in conversation
have one that you use obviously or in my
opinion it's my view just in my opinion
pick one that works for you so have a
number of these set phrases that you can
use
um
pronunciation some people worry about
pronunciation i think having good
phrasing is more important than
pronunciation but if you want to work on
your pronunciation i found
that if you can find some audio content
that you really like where you like the
voice you like the content you like the
intonation
uh
then it becomes almost like music and i
did this with chinese and i listened
over and over and over again to a very
limited range of content and i believe
that that really improved my tones in
chinese so you can do that kind of thing
there are people writing is very good
because when you write you have more
time to think so it gives you time to to
work out how to say things personally i
don't mind using google translate i know
there are a number of things that i
would like to say and check i don't know
how to say them i just type them in
english up comes google translate it's
80 right but it's good enough it gives
me a sense of how i would express these
things in the language and sometimes
i'll even save them into link and and
save those words and phrases for later
use uh there is this technique of
shadowing which i don't do
but where people listen and and repeat
what they're listening to
i just find it very difficult to
continue doing that i've done it on
occasion but
uh you know
the whole thing with language learning
boils down to where do you want to spend
your time
uh
if you have an unlimited amount of time
you can shadow read write listen speak
do everything but if you have an hour or
two a day you have to make a decision
and i find that i'm more motivated to
increase my vocabulary and increase my
comprehension skills and do more reading
rather than to walk around
you know shadowing or talking out loud i
tend not to do that
uh it's possible
that that speeds up the transition to
speaking i don't know because i don't do
it uh i find that
my approach of focusing on building up
my vocabulary
is good enough and then when i get the
opportunity to speak
i just go for it and stumble and make
mistakes and get beaten up and
and go right back at it again and
and it just gradually surprisingly you
you just start to improve
uh a big part of speaking well is to
notice uh how your language differs from
that of the native speaker so when
you're talking to someone you gotta
really
listen clearly to what they're saying
how they use words listen try to a lot
of people don't listen to the
pronunciation of the native language
they try and read it as if it were
english so if there's an a there it's
pronounced a
no
most languages a is pronounced ah so you
really have to pay attention
uh and then start using it try things
out
and not worry about it i think a big
part of of uh one other thing too is is
when you speak you know let go don't say
i'm this foreigner meek mild stumbling
uh
sounding foolish foreigner hey just i'm
here i'm speaking i'm communicating if i
can communicate fine if i can't
i'll do better next time like it's not
such a big deal now all of that is
easier said than done
but
someone asked me what do i do that's
that's what i do at some point i start
speaking and i don't worry about it but
even when i am increasing my speaking
activity i still put most emphasis on
listening and reading so there you have
it and if you have any questions or
comments please don't hesitate